okay welcome people to
this live stream we are talking about
chemistry functionality for wolfram
language
uh for the upcoming release and
supposedly the final review of some
pieces of documentation
so what should i be looking at here
so uh so atom labels will be a new uh
option for molecule plot molecule 3d
i looked at this briefly but i hadn't
made the documentation yet
that's very weird it looks like the
isotope
right um
but it's i would i would put the do we
really want to put the i mean that
position is a nice position i would
think
but what do people usually do for these
kinds of labels for molecules for
atoms i'm not aware of a of a normal uh
of a standard um
okay is there an atom label style as
well
yes but i uh don't have the the dark
page here yet but okay but is that a
thing that we have or is it yes so you
could say label style goes to uh red and
it would work
okay that's bank switching all the atom
labels but what should the for the
default style be
the the default graphics style yes the
default style right now you have it just
black which doesn't seem right to me
you see what i'm saying right okay so i
will uh i will make it but as you ask
graphic design folk i would suggest
something gray or something else that
makes it clear
that it isn't
you know i mean in this particular case
because the hydrogens are gray
it's kind of you know it's sort of
stands out from that but i would suggest
some kind of default color that is more
gray
or something maybe even a background i
don't know maybe even a
maybe even a little box i don't know
maybe that's too
precious and not sensible
but i feel like you you have to enforce
it to get it so
well yeah okay
confusion i feel like
for what
for for mistaking the meaning of the
label as the
there isn't a confusion you say
well there isn't confusion if you were
the one who made it that's what i'm
saying yeah okay i see if you get it
from somebody else right okay
right i just think
okay that's cool cool what you've got
there
so that's going to be the most common
application is labeling stereocenters
but
yeah okay
okay nice
all right
um
okay
next bond labels
for this first release
the bond labels
uh you have to manually provide
a placement to get them not to live on
top of the bonds if like what is
happening with with graphs how does this
work with graphs exactly like this and
so i
i'm we're i'm building a layer on top of
that and if i can get that done before
uh this version
that's that's fine
okay
good
okay
by the way don't forget in
well
yeah don't forget to to link from you
know bond style to edge
bond label to edge label et cetera et
cetera et cetera i don't know whether
you want to link the other way around i
think probably not
right probably probably not
um if edge label is kind of
i don't know whether we should link from
the graph theory stuff to the chemistry
stuff
i would say the other direction
definitely
okay my only reason for saying yes is
that i can imagine that somebody says i
just want to change the edge label
thinking and then they go to the graph
theory i see it now
and then they get confused
but but few chemists would probably call
this an edge
yeah but few
graph theory people would think well
let's look at something
i don't think it'd be bad to just add it
at the very end
of course
now this is called vertex labels
edge labels and you're calling them
singular oh atom labels yeah same thing
all good
there
um
okay what's next
right so a molecule match q is one that
should be fairly quick
and in this case so we discussed this
previously um
i would want to if not
not necessarily deprecate molecule
equivalent q
but just stop linking to it um
so molecule match q
does not
is not var arg in the way that molecule
equivalent q is so it doesn't cover all
the use cases which is why i might
hesitate to throw up well so so i mean
the case that i can imagine as a union
of molecules
same test arrow molecule equivalent q
right that's the case that i mean that's
the you know the the common case is you
just generate a bunch of molecules
maybe algorithmically
and you want to say how many distinct
molecules are there here
what's the best way to do that because
molecule match q will be very very
painful to do that with
well i mean um
so is if that same test is applied on a
on a
pairwise basis
then i would do this i mean the the only
thing that molecule equivalent q does
that molecule match q
doesn't is that it's it takes a whole uh
list all right it takes it takes
it's like like same q it could take
multiple variable number of arguments
well say so we have graph isomorphic
graph q
which i think is pairwise as well
so
i think if that's the case i'm okay with
molecule match q being the primary thing
because i suspect that our our sorting
function
our same test functions are going to be
binary binarize
the way they feed their arguments
so i'm good yeah
so in this case then
the new function
doesn't 100 to cover the the cases of
the old one should i then mark the old
one as deprecated or just keep it and
not knit to it
i would deprecate it okay i think we've
they're all considered experimental now
i would deprecate it before we
have more people use it okay
and just say has been superseded by
martial match queue
include resonance
is that singular the right form
so it could either be include resonant
structures or include resonance so
resonance as the the concept
is
how we interpret it
so include isotopes means pay attention
to isotopes
yes and resonance structure means
if the benzene bonds or something are on
the other foot is that what that means
consider
although in the case of benzene um we
you normalize it internally to make an
uh aromatic anyway so
but there are other cases where you have
bonds uh and um moving around where uh
resonance will be important so none so
yeah but that is essentially the point
well give me my chemistry 15 seconds non
what say it again what what is the case
so when um uh
so you've got double bonds moving around
basically and
the same thing that happens with benzene
but it can happen with non-aromatic
structures also by aromatic you just
mean it's a hexagonal ring
right well so i mean
so if you if you go to alpha we have a
step by step there are some aromatic
structures uh that are not
hexa uh not uh hexagonal but there
there's a set of rules that you that uh
like if the number of
of conjugated electrons in a ring
meets a particular pattern then we then
we deem it to be aromatic you know the
reason i'm asking all of this
is the um
uh
you know i'm slowly backing into
learning chemistry as you know
as we try and understand this molecular
computing stuff
and i'll probably at the end of that i
will understand one very particular kind
of chemistry fairly well
because it'll be the particular you know
implementation layer we're using
but uh
okay i i don't see like include
resonance i think we might want to you
know who knows what that means it could
be a pendulum i mean you know and uh
down on our live stream suggesting
resonance structures
um
yeah that i mean that is clear like
resonance structures when you're in is
it resonance structures or resonant
structures
i left an example in chat for steven to
test the
resonance equivalence
so for example it's false in there
because you didn't check the
measurements
well but but also i um
let's see so that is uh something that's
in the documentation page that it will
work but it is not uh okay at the moment
yet
so we're gonna include resonance will be
i don't understand
why is it saying include why isn't it
not saying ignore
i mean isn't this like ignore case
i'm totally unclear why is this not
saying ignore stereochemistry ignore
isotopes ignore resonance structure
isn't that the right way around i mean
that's what matchq is doing where it
says
ignore case and so on right
it's an interesting point i so we uh i
was just going off of like so we have
include hydrogens as an option
let's
and
but that's different include hydrogens
is an option whether to draw the
hydrogens right
so with with resonance structures though
it um let's see it's not that you're
ignoring so if you want so in the that
case that jan just sent you the one that
uh isn't that should have returned true
when you use
it i thought i thought oh it's string
match q sorry string match q
has
okay so string match q
has ignore case
and then it has spelling correction
right arrow true which means
whether it does spelling correction as
part of string matching
so i mean i think it would be much
clearer if it said ignore if i'm not
mistaken what it means is ignore
stereochemistry the molecules match even
if their stereochemistry is different
correct
yes yes it should be the only so i think
ignore makes sense with isotopes and
stereochemistry and we could
it's harder for me to for it to make
sense about resonance structure okay
explain to me what's going on with
resonance structures what is it actually
doing so essentially i mean the
what it would work or and i know this is
an implementation detail but it um
if it come if you set that option to
true
and the normal so we would do a normal
match and if the normal match came back
false then we would generate all the
resonance structures of
maul
and do the pattern matching until until
we get a true and if we don't i think
that's fine ignore resonance structures
for the match
is the right thing because that's what
that the fact that you're doing it by
enumerating cases is who cares okay the
issue is it doesn't matter what the
resonance structure is it's still going
to match even if the resonance
structures are superficially different
so in that case but go ahead so it would
still have the uh the opposite um uh
option value as the other two yeah yeah
wait wait wait wait
yeah the default option setting is pay
attention to stereochemistry pay
attention to isotopes but don't pay
attention to resonance structures yes
okay i'm fine with that okay
so it would be so ignore resonance
structures
and uh
down on our live stream is asking about
the operator form of this
i don't see any reason it shouldn't have
an operator form these other things have
operator forms you should document it
okay
looks good
all right onward next what's the next
function
chemical
okay what is this puppy doing this one
is the one that actually
makes
wait a minute what is this doing
so it is a symbolic representation of a
species with a particular formula it's
basically
not as good as molecules
but this is what you normally see in a
in the text
c68 or something
okay and but if i want the chemical
formula string out of a molecule what do
i do
use the formula string
sub value
of the molecule okay and if i say
chemical formula of the molecule
will it just make it a bag of atoms
yes so so it will uh yup it'll drop all
of the uh
the bond information
so this will then come back as the same
first line
as that ch whatever it is and if i now
say molecule of this
end of story yeah because then now there
are many possibilities
and how would i generate all those
possibilities
so uh
so essentially uh we have two methods
right now for uh we can look up the in
the knowledge base or look up in pubchem
and uh
we're looking at what function should i
use
so
the sub value of the formula uh
entity isomers or pubchem isomers
so i have another function called isomer
list but i imagine that it would be a
wfr instead
why isn't it a molecule list why isn't
there a molecule list or something a
find molecule
you know
something like find
molecule of a chemical formula or find
molecule
find molecules or something
for a chemical formula
find the isomers it would be i think
more appropriate
here's a confusion maybe michael or
somebody else can help me with this
you know i know more about nuclear
physics i do about chemistry
and an isomer is something in nuclear
physics
it's an excited state of a nucleus
yes
yes i've heard that also uh but in
chemistry we are i mean it is uh it's
very oftenly used uh in
to describe species with the same
formula i know that i know that
i'm just it just every time i hear it it
confuses me slightly because it's
another use
um
and they will find both find molecule
items with any confusion yeah that will
avoid any confusion but i don't
understand why it doesn't just find i
see fine molecular
i mean what it is it's going to i
understand why you don't like find
molecules because it's um
can we give it the second argument how
many and uh option method
i would think so
and then in the future for some classes
we might have uh exhaustive anomaliation
yes
no i have a i mean i have a library that
can generate them exhaustively but it's
it's
it man it's insane how many uh isomers
you can generate from yeah that's why
it's important if a second argument give
me a handle
right
and you might want to sort them a
particular way
like for example possible
well it might be by its frequency of
okay
okay i can't
okay for an elementary for a person
learning elementary chemistry do they
know the term isomer
yes it is it's introduced fairly early
on
okay
um
and so if you prefer that as a function
rather than the sub values i think we
should do this i think it's a useful
function
seems like a function one would use all
the time i mean particularly for more
elementary okay you know maybe i'm
thinking about my own sort of
non-chemistry approach to chemistry so
to speak but i think you know it's like
i've got a graph
tell me i mean i could even imagine that
this could take a graph
and it could do the obvious assumptions
about
uh
you know if it's a full valent thing
it's carbon blah blah blah blah blah
whatever maybe it just is that
completely crazy did i give it graphs
and it just tells me molecules
well no so i mean we have uh we've we
have a graph to molecule
uh conversion like an automatic one
set up i i think it needs a wfr function
for its own options but i haven't
written that yet okay okay fine but this
is a slightly different scenario where
there are not so many possible solutions
so with finding molecule isomers is that
should i try i could try and uh get that
413 or i think it'd be good i think it'd
be very nice okay
okay between find isomers and find
molecule isomers
what what do the more expert people
think about that
they're not opposed to the longer one
sorry find fine molecular isomers would
be less uh
less ambiguous because as you mentioned
you get you get confused between nuclear
isomers and chemical isomers
well but should it then be fine chemical
isomers
but it returns molecules yeah it's
returning molecules
i see now i'm showing my ignorance here
i've nev i didn't know about nuclear
isomers so you know as a chemist
your side of the story is is unusual to
me okay um
so i you know i
it's hard to say what's you know what's
the average user going to expect to know
right
right
by keeping molecule in the name it does
align it with all the other molecule
functions which might help the user just
reduce cognitive load
do we want to find molecule isomers or
do we consider it deterministic
um
no it no it doesn't deterministic
that again it's not it's just it's a
shot in the dark is what you're saying
depending on what's available in the
resources in pubchem or in the entities
what what would we make the default
value for how many and the method
right no so i think that's that's a
really good question because to me i've
there is and also like it's not clear
that it should always return molecules
because sometimes it is useful
like in that example to get the list of
uh of entities
without first uh
oh i see what you mean and yeah calling
to entity on them
um
and so it's not clear so to me it seems
like the second argument might tell you
what you want how you want so the second
argument would be then string something
like
pubchem knowledgebase or something like
algorithmic
maybe hold on so that that uh
that details the the method used rather
than the the return type yeah i think
it's the return type we want but there
but but the method implies the return
type yeah it really does so if you're
going to publish
external identifiers or exactly we can't
get entities for things that we don't
have as entities right
okay so it will be entity molecule
pubchem id
is that right and i and i think that the
way to deal with the
you know maybe there's a max items
option as there is a web image search or
something you know web image search
you're going to get a potentially
infinite number
and then well the problem is
look
i think it's got to be an argument
because
because you really want the case of all
for some small molecules you might want
to say all
right
that definitely would be the case in a
classroom environment where you're
working with you know 10 12 atoms and
showing this off
but even if it were an option you could
still say max items goes to all yeah you
could you're good and all we could make
all the default
no that should do no
but why not do this
well i mean
look why not make this it's either going
to be all it's going to be up to
basically it's going to say
up to the default is going to be up to
10 or something yeah
okay
or it could be dependent on the molar
mass of the or
atom count of the
whatever you're inputting no
fine you the number of iterations for
example um in fine minimum is a fixed
number it does not look at the problem
right i agree
yeah okay all right
you know all right find isomers probably
is the right thing given it isn't always
returning a molecule
and this looks like a good thing to have
so second argument would be entity
or
molecule
molecule and probably as courtesy allow
the ones as straight as non-strings or
pubchem id
if that's what we're calling the pubchem
id right pubg compound id is with what's
called in the external identifier
yeah okay
okay well so long as it auto completes
people will be able to find that
um and are there any other
types of identifiers it might be
the cass regnose might be reasonable
so
yeah and so i would add more as i'm able
to hook up uh the connections to the
to the sources
arc is asking on a live stream can you
show shows spectrometer readout
presumably mass spectrometer from the
chemical formula how would you generate
that
no you could
yeah you definitely could uh i haven't
so i let's see so when i was in graduate
school one of the very few uh
experiments that told things that i did
was uh the ta for ptm lab and we looked
at a mass spectra um
and so i think it involves looking at
the the isotope
distribution it would have to be for the
molecular ion mm-hmm
it depends which mine the i mean for
these particular materials
whether it's crustal abundance or not
right um
yeah i i do think that that would be
interesting um
were they asking for the mass spectrum
or the well they just said spectrometer
so so i think they might
you can break it up and get the spectrum
of all the different atoms that are in
there and then you can get all break
apart the bonds and get different uh so
just so i understand what is we have the
atomic what do we have what is it called
what is the tongue
you mean the spectra the atomic line
specter
why isn't it
what what is it
no it's called difficulty
how is it spectral line data
yeah
yeah yeah so there if we'd say that and
then we say
like carbon for example
what are we going to get
carbon has a lot
okay that's that's like the third
ionized yeah so how do i actually get
the spectral lines
oh look at the left
you page say in this uh
in this range and
why is it okay okay there's a lot of
interesting stuff here all right let's
not get distracted
um
okay all right so chemical formula
so from this
further down there are some examples of
getting isomales
i
see
but that says pubchem isomers well okay
that's just a method option yeah which
we now change now this would return ids
other than molecules with new designs
yeah
i have a question i mean how common
is molecular mass and should it just be
a function as well as being this
property
no so i would i so i would definitely i
would make it a
a function so that way it could just be
a molecule an atom it's one of the most
used things in alpha what people ask
why don't we just have it be a function
as well as being this property
yeah
molecular mass of percent
well but there's three flavors of
molecular mass
so what well what
well you have the molecular mass and
atomic units you have the relative
atomic mass which has no units and then
you have the molar mass which is grams
per mole
another two argument functions yeah
there's a two argument function what's
the default um
so i would this one here
yeah yeah yeah i agree yeah the more
molecular mass
so you could specify the units as an
option
yes not as an option as a second
argument ah okay
are there any other
things that are like super common is
molar mass its own thing that's worth
having a function out of
given that it's just a change of units
from molecular mass it seems
overkill to have both
yeah maybe
there are calls on our live stream for
all kinds of spectra roman spectra ir
spectra and so on
so uh
if we could go back to the find isomers
uh yep since um
we're coming up with the design right
now um let's see so you could specify
molecule entity or pubchem but uh
by default should i search in all of
those places like so it's let's say you
say molecule
i could go to both sources or all
sources when i started hooking up
findings well you seem to have a way to
represent molecules by pubchem what what
is this
are these all things which go ahead
right so for so you make a call to
pubchem and tell them the formula and
they spit back a list of um
a list of ids
and then in this particular case i have
to then uh go back to the to those ids
and filter out so here's what i think
you should do
i think it should default to molecule i
think the default behavior should be
just pick up things that we
know about so to speak i think if we
don't find any there we go out and look
at the pubchem case
okay in other words i think if we get so
the corner case is there are seven an
hour that we get in our knowledge base
right
and but
if we went to pub chem we would get
another
four
okay do we return seven or do we wait
and return ten
i think we return seven
but at the moment pumpkin is doing the
heavy lifting right they're doing the
search for us so if you look uh above so
in that example that's right in front of
you that we have one entity with that uh
okay well if you think we're gonna need
to use pubchem in most cases then i
would then that's what i would do i mean
but i would sort the ones we have in
front yep
okay yeah understood and uh um yeah and
molecule has the ability to hold meta
information so it can store the fact
that it came from an entity or from
pubchem for you
is that obvious in the summary box that
it there's an entity for it
no so the user would know that
no but i mean so we have two entities it
works on uh
maybe you could not put it in the
summary books okay they
i mean you know stephen had suggested
that they'd be up front so how is the
user going to know is that the first six
or the first ten that doesn't matter
okay fine i i think it's just let's give
preference to those because you know
there was a reason why they're in our
knowledge base
yeah
okay um
okay and q our live stream is mentioning
machine learning of spectra yes we've
had multiple summer school projects on
that subject
um
for these commenting that engineers will
expect grams per mole
for molecular mass i cannot comment on
that
let's see so actually i mean so we have
there is an option so the problem with
the second argument is that you can't
call set options on it um
uh whether that's a problem or uh i
don't think it's a big problem okay
because just there is a there is an
option that matches that right it's um
you build your own code
yeah you're right you you make your own
curried form
right or you just have a function that
does it well i'm sorry what are the
things what what what's the option
uh target units
okay well fine so if you set target
units it'll do the right thing or you
can explicitly use the second argument
okay all right let's let's move on next
item the next would be chemical reaction
slowly gets interesting
okay do you think you have a
representation for these things
i mean we're trying
so
we kind of touched on this topic
previously that um
that we have basically two different
forms of a chemical reaction
as a data structure
one that represents a reaction and has
stoichiometric coefficients
and it can be balanced you can take it
an unbalanced one and you can balance it
and then we have a uh a structural
transformation like a a reaction that
obviously as this atom goes to here yeah
and you need to have atom mapping
between the reactants and products you
don't put coefficients in front of
things you don't balance why wouldn't
you have coefficients
i mean oh i see because you have because
you have to
you know how i'm using this is you know
in in terms of our discussion about this
multi-computation power line this is
token deduplication whether you have
whether those two water molecules are
considered the same thing
in one case they're not right if you're
going to track which atom went well
obviously those are two distinct water
molecules otherwise quantum mechanically
you expect the water molecules to be
identical
right and you just looked at the stuff
before and then you turned your head and
looked back and you have products and
you don't know
which atom went to where you can you can
use your intuition to write that kind of
stuff down
but uh
um
for the purposes of this data structure
it doesn't matter
and also like this one which we have in
front of us everything is totally
expertise there is nothing which has a
dangling thing that doesn't
matter i understand so comment about
this
we have this notion of entity
oh gosh what is it when you have three
baseballs or something how is that
represented in the entity framework uh
entity group or an end of the instance
you made
yes
which we haven't used very much
but this is a place where we could at
least support that
couldn't we i mean isn't that the right
way to think about this this is
you know three zinc hydroxide molecules
seems like it's the same kind of things
three baseballs
yes so
there would a little bit limit us for
things only that are entities if we
would have say a couple expected
complicated molecules that we don't have
we don't well fine i'm not saying okay
fine okay so this is how you prefer are
you opposed to the to entity instance
being wrapped around something that is
that has head chemical formula or
molecule
a little bit abusive but it's not
obviously wrong
okay good so yeah so we have a wfr right
now that is for chemical conversions and
uh we're going to extend it to take
entity instance
um
fine
what does it do what is that what
convert three grams of uh of benzene to
milliliters
or i see
or a lot more complicated ones than that
but that's the basics okay so it's
similar to the wall from alpha
functionality for that yes
we need it for vein because it's a very
popular topic
okay
well and so one day we might want to
design that as an language type thing
yes
okay i hope
look
this business about how
you know like
i mean i'm wondering sure you can have
this property but
you know i just wonder if it's if it's
the thing that you're always doing is
this reaction balanced
shouldn't there be reaction balanced q
so to speak
it does see a lot of use so promoting it
would wouldn't hurt
okay it would be nice to have a function
separate function for it yes fine
okay but so now in terms of the
representation reaction this is the
non-tract
token deduplicated version of this
reaction
you know it has to be telling one
something that the the by the way are
there any other examples here or not yet
no not yet okay so what do you think
it's going to look like when you're
tracking
atoms
so i um yeah so i wanted to know if you
want to have a meeting to talk about
that next week and so i can send you
i'll paste it in chat i haven't like so
we've been batting back and forth within
the group uh
what we didn't think we would have
enough time in this meeting to discuss
the complicated version okay but i just
give me a sense because i'm trying to
understand it as we try and design this
one
so um if you so i just pasted uh
you said
you would just use the functional groups
for this right you just use the penises
and see if they would match
so you have some template so you say i
have a
little group there
and they react and then i know that this
is an ester or something
could do something like this you know i
have a feeling none of you were in the
meeting about uh design for
multi-computation i was i was there oh
okay
yesterday no no not yesterdays okay
you would have helped yesterdays the um
okay
basically what
you know
that case is all about you're taking an
expression and you're here's what that
involves you take an expression you
rewrite sub-expressions you glue the
resulting thing back into the expression
which i think is very much the same kind
of thing
don't you have exactly the same issue
with molecules
that is you've got this big hunking
molecule it's got this little piece that
has a reaction
or is that not what happens what does it
so
more or less what happens yeah and so
we've got two functions i i've okay are
you pasting something in somewhere
because i don't see this oh he did we
put it i don't know
jason you only sent it to me oh i'm
sorry so that's right i did see it they
say well it doesn't happen
sorry about that
okay so hold on
um
okay comment from marco here
please include a progress bar saying
checking public databases
yes if no so i'm using uh evaluate with
progress for the uh
okay fine so it does do that
and so so here
yeah that uh that i mean so it's a big
example like the the poly polymerization
of amino acids but it's the basic point
that you have patterns
going to other patterns and you
um label the atoms
with uh with a mapping number
okay this is so freaking analogous to
what we're going to need for these
it's fascinating
you know chemistry has been ahead of all
of this stuff for millions of years
apparently
um
first it has all the baggage well no it
just has all the baggage of having
actual molecules as opposed just
idealized you know uh symbolic
expressions
okay but so what you're saying here
right so you write a pattern that
matches a substructure and you lit you
mark the individual pieces of that
substructure
and then you can refer to them on the
other side of the of the arrow yeah i
get it but why are we not i mean we've
got a whole system for this it's called
x blank
x is a named pattern variable
why isn't this the same story so okay so
if i did x and then colon and then uh an
atom as a pattern on the left hand side
of the rule and then i switched the the
rule to being a rule delayed i wanted to
write it like that
but sometimes you need to make
specifications about that pattern when
it appears on the other side so on the
left hand side it was um
atom carbon uh
hydrogen count goes to two or a formal
charge goes to one and then on the right
it now has a different charge and you
need to specify that i know someone why
why isn't this variable why aren't you
doing it with in this example here
um
i would have said
uh
so here
if it's the nitrogen thing it's called
you know nnn colon
and then that's the nitrogen thing and
then it could have a different
atom nnn hydrogen count on the other
side so long as atom has the right kind
of ident potent so to speak
that should work as opposed to saying
here you know nn colon
which means it's the whole
atom with that hydrogen count
if that made sense in other words this
is representing the atom without
hydrogens presumably
and this is representing the outside one
is representing that atom with its with
its uh you know ancillary hydrogens
and by the way if you did it this way
you know we could also deal with bonds
if you care about that i don't know
whether you do care about that
we do we do but normally um let's see so
it's only the so
you would change the bond between two uh
mapped
atoms
yeah the bond pattern usually goes along
with it um when we write the molecule
patterns for the reactants
uh and the products so
um
okay i think we just have to play with
with some ideas here to see what's right
but i i strongly suggest
that using the pattern matching scheme
that we already have
is the right thing and arguably
you know one could have a full form of
that sea
that you know because i can imagine all
kinds of stuff like like saying you know
it can either be
sulfur or fluorine or something
somewhere exactly
chlorine versus bromine versus i yeah
that's very common and also about the
bonds whether you care about the bonds
or only that it's a ring
okay
and so let's see so so a i mean um
let's see so with that example right
there when you have a uh
a reaction with 20 mapped atoms
it would be um
a nuisance to name one risk to have to
to label them or i mean even just
writing them out like this is is a
nuisance
um but coming up with unique symbols
well fine but i mean but we can have all
kinds of different ways to align that
the question is what the default
behavior is i mean you know could even
be that something notationally like this
is supported but it's just what is the
full form how do we actually think about
this
and to me yeah
so to me that um that c colon
six
is
atom
carbon comma atom map number goes to six
and i
so i know that it does it's
we shouldn't let other languages dictate
how we do things but uh
reactions smiles and smarts and all of
these things
do have a notion of adverb mapping and
so if we want to import them then we
need it yeah
look it's also the case
in
this is very reminiscent and i suspect
the same thing will come up okay so
were you to have a genome string
and you say oh i'm going to have i'm
going to remove this i'm going to delete
this this thing at that position
i have no idea what the notation then is
for the coordinate system if you get
what i'm saying
right so i mean there's a coordinate
system on the genome
but clearly that canonical coordinate
system doesn't include deleted elements
if you have a snip i mean that's why
snips tend to get labeled you know rs
whatever it is
because there isn't in fact a coordinate
system and my point here is
numbering things like this
let's imagine you had a polymer of some
kind
and you start removing pieces of it i
mean maybe nobody cares about this at
this point in the history of chemistry
so to speak
but you get what i'm saying that that
that
numbering is not
oh i don't know maybe this is an
irrelevant point i mean maybe i'm just
too concerned with what happens with
strings and this multi-computation stuff
with strings
your points well taken about numbering
and it is fragile you you discover after
you've been working on it that you know
you've left an atom out and you need to
insert it in the middle and half your
numbers are wrong now
um or something like that
well it's like it's like house numbering
you know in some countries
you know in the u.s people tend to
number houses with zero zeros so they
can stick other ones in between
whereas in the uk they number them
sequentially and then you end up with
you know 12
b and things like this
yeah yeah
but i i think we should try using the
the built-in uh
pattern
uh expression patterns
to see what we can do
uh i i've been trying to write a number
of these reactions for jason as examples
and i've been sticking with the uh
atom mapping numbering that comes from
smarts and smirks
because it's just easier to get the
input in but i can try doing some
with uh more traditional world from
language patterns and see what we can do
see what happens right
i mean so so however they work like i'm
going to have to write a parser for that
and so
so we'll talk about it jason we'll see
what we can but i also would like to
point out
that programmatically generating these
things with colons will be very painful
so it seems to me i've always thought
any i don't think there's any
non-painful way of mapping the atoms and
that the best way to do it will be
uh graphically like with a with an
interactive
but how are we going to do it there what
are you doing you're going to draw a
line from one to the other i would so i
would have the the reactants on the left
the products on the right and i would
click adam adam adam adam and then it
was like but then it's got a bunch of
pentacles it's got a bunch of threads
going from one to the other is that
right physiola
something like that i don't remember how
they used to do it in the old max system
but they did support reactions in there
and i'm quite sure they entered them
graphically so
is it does it end up with some crazy
color matching thing where the purple
carbon is going to the purple carbon
nobody can nobody can recognize colors
so does it end up with a thread yeah
well
they didn't have color
so i didn't do the thread what i have is
um
mousing over like so when you mouse over
an atom on on the left side of the ring
yeah flash is on the other side yeah
um you and you mark the ones that aren't
done yet
blah
right so the version of reaction plot
that i have is definitely not going to
be ready
the the um
you know as a test case imagine a graph
and imagine trying to mark off graph
isomorphism that way
which would be i mean like just imagine
that you're doing
an isomeric
you know no actually just imagine
you were simply reconfiguring the same
molecule i i assume there are molecules
that do that that can be in one shape or
another that yes that does happen
doesn't it
yes yes what's an example just for my
chemistry knowledge
which one
wolvelin uh let me type the spelling of
yeah bulvaleen yeah it it rearranges uh
cation rearrangements and uh you can
essentially scramble all the atoms and
maintain the same bonding
lovely are we talking about
tautomerization or is it more
okay
um
ethan is asking about self-interactions
and rna strands wrong team to be talking
about that
um you're working on that tool
okay
not completely wrong team to be talking
about that okay
marco is commenting on external
connections to spectrometer devices i
think we leave that to our friends at
emerald who have been doing that
very seriously
um
are there chemical equilibrium and
kinetics capabilities in the chemical
reaction object what is it what does the
chemical reaction object record about
kinetics
right so that is a future extension so
once we get the data structure in there
um
it takes a second argument of with
parameters and
you could specify a forward reaction
rate and a backward reaction rate those
kinds of things i mean it's a function
of temperature and so on presumably and
everything else could be installed yes
you know i mean the only reactions i
know about particle reactions and one
can imagine you know
pi pion proton scattering going to
whatever and it would work more or less
the same way
and one would say you know in that case
there's a cross section as a function of
energy i don't think chemists usually
talk about cross-sections but you
certainly could right
yeah no i mean so yeah no reaction
cross-section is a definitely a thing
okay
but then
i mean these atoms that come i mean in
the in the in particle physics you would
be worrying about the asymptotic states
and the question is if you've got a zinc
sulfate coming in is every zinc sulfate
like every others in sulfate
is it considered that that thing is just
some sort of ground state object that's
just sort of coming into the reaction
and then it goes into the you know then
it scatters in this reaction is that
right or the or the hast
it might matter if it's introduced as a
solid or a liquid
it also depends on reaction conditions
if white catalyzes it it might be in an
excited state
temperature could change the vibrational
properties which also could facilitate a
particular migration of bonds
can change it
no no i understand that but an isotope
is not going to change it's not going to
transmute itself on on you know in
flight
um
no but if you put deuterated water into
regular water that the deuterated um
high the deuterated hydrogens are going
to move around
yes yeah get hydrogen exchange
yep
um so if i could just uh to answer that
that question from the live stream
having the chemical reaction here
next the next steps would be functions
like chemic reaction thermodynamics and
react and um
not you wouldn't have a function called
reaction kinetics you would have uh
some type of uh
of function that could
monitor uh um concentrations over time
and one of the things that it would need
would be a list of reactions and then a
list of
um things in your beaker you could have
a function called beaker right or petri
dish or okay
i have to i have to go to something and
minus some number of minutes here um
the uh
do we
it looks like as a matter of fact my
calendar has a has a gap for something
that must have just dropped out um do we
want to continue this this afternoon or
do we want to um
uh how much more do we have to do
so
that was all that i had for today and
with the idea that i would ask do you
would you have time to meet uh early
next week to talk about twitter
i'd love to meet about template
reactions but i haven't a clue i i can
go work with the scheduler with you to
figure that out
fine um
that chemical x is smaller containers
where you can do these stoichiometry you
can balance equations you have something
like this this is what is a foot in the
door for chemical reaction and 13 and
then the template would be then in a
later version
look the thing i really want to think
about and i know it's kind of a heavy
lifting type thing
is i really think this is so incredibly
similar to these you know
transformations for this
this uh multi-computation business and i
i just want to kind of think about what
we can learn from the chemistry case for
that and vice versa
but i don't don't you know you should
get a complete model for what to do with
chemistry and then we'll worry about how
to move those two things next to each
other so to speak
um so in the meeting so
i assume you are fine with chemical
reaction the one that is absolutely
expertise and no ambiguity
yeah in in the meeting about template
next week that
just mentioned anybody else who should
be there for
with respect to the moody
paradigm
ah
ask again i'm not sure okay
not sure
it's not clear i mean
uh maybe carlo
b
um
not sure
okay and actually what you've said about
catalysts
both catalysts and um
i mean okay so
there's multiple cases you can have
no i mean you know in my kind of amateur
thinking about sort of the future of
chemistry so to speak
this whole business about actually
tracking
sort of you know because
most of what you're thinking about in
chemical reactions is it has a certain
temperature it has whatever
it's not you know that particular atom
had this particular set of properties
anyway never mind the different
different topic
um all right looking wonderful let's um
will to be continued early next week i
guess
thank you very much